what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with our x-men
chronology which we've moved to Sundays
we're gonna cheat a little bit we're
actually gonna kind of take part of a
story and cover that not really part of
a story here's the deal
so as part of the whole aftermath to the
House of M which is to say the Scarlet
Witch taking everybody's powers there
were a whole bunch of ancillary stories
that came out of this and it was really
kind of like reworking and revitalizing
the x-men for the villain apocalypse who
had long so long stood as one of the
x-men's most dangerous villain he had
always had something called the four
horsemen
and the four horsemen originally as they
were introduced well really with lluís
and Walter Simonson the whole idea was
to basically have the four horsemen be
this kind of Marvel Comics embodiment of
like the Four Horsemen of Bill of the
biblical apocalypse from the Book of
Revelations now the idea was that
originally apocalypse would grab mutants
whose powers complemented the role he
would give them so for example one of
the the really one of the first members
of the four horsemen was a Morlock
called plague who had the ability to
spread like disease and illness and
apocalypse turned her into pestilence
now because of the fact that apocalypse
having horsemen was such a popular
concept which is really kind of like
bolstered by x-men the animated series
the idea of the horse and themselves
became wildly popular and so it was one
of those things where every time
apocalypse showed up he usually have a
different set of horsemen just because
of the fact that the horsemen he had
before had been defeated but over the
years Marvel began to kind of move away
from the powers have to complement the
world a play to just what would make a
really cool horseman now by and large
when apocalypse has this four horsemen
really like the being death is kind of
like the the cut above the rest
usually when apocalypse sits down and
says Who am I going to make it to my
horsemen there's pestilence there's
famine these different roles that people
play and then there's death and death is
like usually the most popular one that
was a trend that was set in motion with
angel with when Warren Worthington
became the horseman death and it was
cool because I mean he was leading like
famine and war and pestilence and it was
cool to see him leading those those
particular roles but the fact remains
here that the the character the person
who plays death is always the most
popular
the only exception of that I think is
the Incredible Hulk who was war but like
Wolverine for example was the horseman
death at one point along line and so the
idea and we'll talk more about this once
we actually cover the blood of
apocalypse story but the idea was that
with this story blood of apocalypse it
was essentially a scenario whereby
apocalypse had been woken up from his
slumber by virtue of the fact that so
many mutants had lost their powers just
this massive
and energy just kind of snapped it out
now remember when it comes to apocalypse
he usually lays down and slumbers to
kind of rejuvenate his abilities and it
could depend Marvel just kind of plays
it fast and loose on how long he sleeps
for the most part it's usually for
anywhere between a few thousand years
sometimes even as short is like a few
hundred years but the idea is that ever
since apocalypse first woke up within
the last you know couple thousand years
or so the idea was that he's been on a
constant crusade to try to take over the
world now eventually he'll go back into
his slumber and he'll sleep for like
another two thousand years and then when
he emerges he'll try to take over the
world again which he successfully dead
in cable's future but the whole idea is
that when he emerged when he basically
woke up he actually showed up on the
grounds of the X of the Xavier Institute
of the x-men mansion and was like I come
here with vials of my blood those who
believe in me drink my blood and he will
basically gain your powers you'll get
your powers back or get some kind of
powers back and those of you who don't
feel free to just kind of live down here
in the slums so to speak and so what you
ended up having was kind of like this
mutant civil war to a degree you had
those who were faithful to apocalypse
and those who were not the idea was that
gambit turned himself over to apocalypse
and we didn't know why what this does is
it explains why but it kind of gives us
like the transmogrification of gambit
which is to say the process he undergoes
to a degree on how he becomes the
horseman death now it's kind of funny
because when he first showed up to
apocalypse it was well the actually
never appreciated me so I'm turning
myself over to you because hopefully you
could show some measure of appreciation
I remember most all the x-men know who
apocalypse is and for those of you guys
who are not familiar the apocalypse you
saw in the Fox movie that was a sham
that's that's nowhere near how powerful
apocalypse is apocalypse is crazy
powerful like he could augment any of it
he can offer in his body to become
anything he didn't give himself the
power of flight he can change his lens
and like weapons and shields and like
energy projections and you know like
like shoot energy beams and things like
that he can grow to like any size he can
shape-shift it's crazy the kind of
powers he displaced he's a one-man army
and if it really came down to it this is
kind of a funny thing about the
character of apocalypse because he's so
powerful you don't really see him fight
the x-men all that often and usually the
way the fights happen is apocalypse
shows up he sends forth his horsemen his
first were defeated apocalypse says you
know he says fine I'll see you guys next
time but if it came down to it and
apocalypse like you know you wanted to
write a story where apocalypse killed
the x-men he would just show up at the
Xavier Institute he would just blah
the entirety of the Xavier Institute
every single x-man that tried to face
off against him would stand no chance
they would be totally obliterated and
apocalypse would just walk away that
story would be like three pages long it
would not be huge and it would fit in
because he's just that damn powerful
it's crazy how capable he is but gambit
showing up it's one of these interesting
things because when your gambit and
you've been part of the x-men in a lot
of ways he has the right to feel
betrayed because he has been multiple
times your wig and it first showed up
back in the old exit the end the old
uncanny x-men stories his appearance
came with the fact that he was very
ambiguous nobody really knew anything
about his past when the x-men discovered
that he had basically led the the
Marauders of mr. sinister into the
tunnels of New York and then the
Marauders had engaged in the Morlock
massacre while gambit did not partake in
the massacre the x-men thought he did
and they immediately kicked him off the
team they wouldn't even let him plead
his case they just kicked him off the
team and that was the end of that no
gambit eventually came back but has
always been this idea - despite the fact
that gambit is been part of the x-men
the x-men have never fully trusted him
now a lot of us because gambits never
really like put all his cards on the
table so to speak he's never laid his
whole life to bear for the x-men to see
he has with rogue to a degree but even
the conversations with rogue have been
like don't tell anybody else what I've
told you because this is very important
to me that kind of a thing and so
because of that it's one of those
scenarios where he really is very
mysterious even in the eyes of the x-men
in a lot of different ways and so when
he shows up here and he hands himself
over to apocalypse in a lot of ways he
kind of wants to believe it's kind of
that desire to belong somewhere you know
where apocalypse shows up it says I will
make this world better I will give you
guys your powers back you know gambit
kind of wants to believe that it wants
to say look you're going to make the
world a better place I hope you will
because you can but it's also kind of
funny too because gambit ask questions
like what in the world is that thing do
and in Apocalypse is like ah that's the
cloth Horace and I actually don't really
know it just kind of messes with your
body a little bit I guess
now this is kind of funny here because
in truth apocalypse inherently like
let's say for example we strip away all
the technology of apocalypse he's just a
mutant who's immortal and is like really
strong and that's really about it
apocalypse is the ability to access
celestial technology that's what grants
him all the special powers that he has
that's what elevated him from just like
an external illegitimate Lee immortal
mutant
to like a godly like a demigod that's
that's the only thing that really
elevated him to that position is a
celestial Tech but it's might having
meddled with it to a degree
apocalypse doesn't understand it fully
he understands like the if you expose
someone to it and you set the Machine in
motion it'll start augmenting their
powers and they'll come out either with
a new set of powers or with like a
heightened heightened level of their
existing powers but apocalypse doesn't
understand it 100% of the way and that's
kind of the interesting thing is because
for him if you go back and you read the
old like cable and Deadpool stories
where it talks about how cable was the
traveler and he went back and met
apocalypse for the first time and like
fought him and was the reason why
apocalypse was able to augment with
celestial technology anyway despite the
fact that he had this access his mind
couldn't necessarily comprehend this
technological stuff that was there that
was hundreds of thousands if not
millions of years way ahead of anything
humanity was able to achieve even it
right now in the modern day apocalypse
being able to use celestial technology
is essentially you being exposed to like
an alien space spacecraft and then being
able to turn it on that's basically what
it amounts to like okay cool you turned
it on awesome alright now like you know
if I do this this thing happens but I
don't really know why it happens I just
know that it does happen that's just
kind of how apocalypse functions when it
comes to that celestial attack now the
other half of this is also ascribe
Ozymandias now I remember
Ozymandias was one of the generals of
Cain the Conqueror backwood Cain the
Conqueror lived in ancient Egypt an
apocalypse first rose to power
now pocalypse of course uses power to
essentially turn Ozymandias into like
living stone and the idea was that from
that point until the end of time
Ozymandias would be doomed to do nothing
more than just chronicle the events of
apocalypse every action apocalypse makes
every action that takes place that's the
result of Apocalypse all those different
things that's the entire role Ozymandias
plays and nothing more than that but it
is kind of funny because apocalypse
initially tries to play on the idea of
gambit feeling abandoned by the xmin
which game it kind of allows them to do
to a degree but then we learn gambits
true motivation and what gambit
basically says here is I'm not doing
this because I truly believe in you I
believe you might do something good I
believe that like you're you say you
want to do some good things but I'm
doing this because somebody's got to
keep an eye on you that as the horseman
death my powers which were already
formidable will be augmented and
heightened and in your hubris you will
likely leave then I cannot take you down
and so when these events unfold when
everything begins to come to fruition if
what we find out is that this whole
charade
like I'm here to make everything better
and I'm here to bring you guys to a
better place you know if that's all just
a facade and if it's really just classic
apocalypse who's using the moment to try
to seize control of the world if that's
really all it is
then gambit will be there to stop him
now whether or not gambit could truly do
it on his own
we'll have to wait until we get to the
story to find out but this is the
process by which gambit undergoes to
become the horseman death and let me
tell you some man like as horseman death
he looks amazing dude he looks so good
he's one of the coolest looking Horsemen
of apocalypse that there's ever been
with like the all black and the red eyes
and like the long hair it looks so beast
he's pretty amazing but I figured you
guys might enjoy this I thought you guys
might dig this whole thing of like
gambit becoming a horseman of apocalypse
becoming the horseman death but what
we'll do is next week where we jump back
into our x-men videos again we'll cover
the actual blood of apocalypse story
which technically takes place before
deadly Genesis we could fit it in
chronologically and what does it kind of
say where it fits in but it is one of
those cool stories so without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here too comments
explained to make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the robb
cork you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]